ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show two very special guests we've
been trying to get them for six years
and I emailed their I would text your
producer once every couple of weeks for
the last several years and we finally
we've done it we've got it we've got it
done but Tim you're so fantastic and
busy that's well
this gentleman is at me and you could
have done yeah 90 hours of broadcasting
we could have started a podcast in the
time you should yeah we should like we
could have and you're back now from the
tour I'm back from the tour yeah I'm
very excited to do this you know we we
it was never there are people that you
go like you know I'm just busy right and
that's your way of being like I don't
like you right but for you yeah
for you it was real where I was I really
was gone and um yeah no of course it was
you know occasionally somebody asked me
to do something yeah and they'll be like
I'm like dude I'm not in New York and
then I'll look at my Instagram story
there's a photo of me holding a bagel on
59th Street you know what I mean like
I'm very I'm a bad liar we're all the
same with that [__] though everybody
wants to like you there's the things you
want to do because you like the person
or you guys click or you're a fan of
which we're all that with you like
relaxation and and it's always been fun
to watch your your crazy rise in all
this [__] but um it is like an art form
to be of how to get out of things within
this world in the comedy podcast world
you're always like no the thing is dude
I um
I'm having ankles yeah
I thought you broke here I'm like no I
did but I found out my ankle's weak too
so I use my mother a lot because she's
in a mental institution yeah that's a
good one so I just go what's great is
like my mother's not doing well now
here's the thing my mother's never been
doing well yeah it's been 30 years of my
mother not doing well I don't even know
what my mother doing well would look
like
what would that even be yeah she's a
morbidly obese schizophrenic so if my
mother walked to the door of her room
and opened it herself it's a win
what's great about that is I just go you
know my mother's not doing well yeah so
I'm gonna just take some time with her
yeah I'm just kidding and everybody has
to go like yeah I guess and you love
spending time with her I love it I do it
four times a year yeah and now I do it
as much as I can but you know what it is
she forgets when I'm there a lot so I go
is this it real
um they've just given her a phone like
she got whatever the version of the new
Obama phone is but it's like it's a
phone they're giving to lunatics and she
can't turn it on and can't use it but
it's one of those State programs like
remember when they gave Obama phones out
they're like the problem with all these
people so they can't communicate but if
they had the tools to communicate they'd
build a network of people and you know
they you know I don't know Marshall
their resources together is it like a
jitterbug is it like huge numbers
it's a phone it's just [__] she'll
never answer my aunt texted me her
number I'll call her now there's no way
she answers there's no way she answers
because my aunt please answer my aunt
text me goes your mother has a phone and
doesn't know how to use it so I just
ignore these texts I just go like
she goes your mom is a phone she doesn't
know how to use it we're gonna have to
teach her I'm like well I'm not doing
that
she's 70. if she can't use a phone let's
write it off yeah
let's see there's no way please answer
what's her name Patricia
you don't have it saved I don't have it
saved
she's gonna lose it she's gonna lose it
there's no way she has this in a month
she's gonna say that if one of the black
orderly stolen
because she's racist yeah yeah she's a
racist person my mom was so racist when
she died like my mother was
schizophrenic too that's what Tim and I
have in common and I when I went to
clean out her apartment because she was
a shut-in for eight years
um I met the security guard that would
look in on her from time to time yeah
and I was like hey I'm Christina I know
we've never met because I've never
[__] visited my mother right and I go
I'm Edith's daughter and she goes oh
yeah
I remember her she goes uh she's an
African she goes yeah yeah she goes you
know she was okay to me
she never called me the n-word oh geez
and I was like that implies that she's
been calling other people other people
yeah other people oh man
um yeah but not her not her so that was
a win yeah I don't think my mother's
using the n-word but she will
not yet she'll get there but like I will
sit down with her and she'll be like
um she'll go uh there are too many
Muslims in the country and I'm like is
that your biggest problem you've been
immobile for 20 years pretty much and
you're you're in this room and all you
can do is watch television and scream
and Muslims right here Muslims are
bothering you
but that's the way I get out of things
and my mother did tell me when I was
little she goes just tell people I'm
dead she said that to me if you need to
get out of something just tell something
that wasn't one of the nicest things
ever very nice thing oh yeah it's one of
I mean everybody who has kids end up
ends up knowing this that it is the
great like cancel Clause it's like when
someone's like hey do you wanna you're
like dude I got yeah right and then
other parents know it they're like yeah
yeah but they respect it other people
like it's code oh yeah it's code yeah
you don't want to do this and you're
like yeah of course kids so most
comedians don't have that like not like
a lot of comedians have that but a lot
of a lot of us unfortunately are single
there are some of us that go hey I'm a
pedophile
I can't do it there are some people that
can you know
can I say that I can't really uh I can't
make it Saturday
um
um now do you guys ever get in do you do
your kids have friends whose parents are
cool
yeah rarely yeah no there's like there's
the ones where you're like here's the
thing
our bar if anything is so high for what
it's like to hang out with someone
that's true like none of none of the
kids
parents are at the level of like I'm
saying of fun and entertaining as like
commit like the most fun thing about
being a comedian really is hanging out
with other comedians 100 it's the best
like having dinner the hangs in the
parking lot after the sets you're like
this I could do this forever you do that
night after night after night after
night and then you can hang out with
like some kids parents you're like I
want to [__] die so your bar for that
you're like if this person is marginally
cool and fun it's it's entertaining
enough like the worst is children's
parties actually it's usually my kids to
like a Chuck E cheese and then you know
you have to make Chit Chat which is a
southern [__]
Chit Chat Small Talk which I can't do I
wouldn't put a gun in my mouth right
talking about the weather or what are
you gonna do this summer oh Jesus Christ
you know I like taking comedy right like
that's the worst good uh they're like
yeah they just kind of smile and look at
you and they're like you got any new
stuff and you're like what the [__] are
you doing yeah what is this about yeah
you got any new stuff no do you think
you'll ever have children I don't know
um I'm deeply selfish yeah um this is a
problem I think when you have children
yes yes
I if I had kids I'd want to spend a lot
of time with them like Bert
[Laughter]
you know what I mean like I'd want to
give them the attention and no I don't
know like
if I found a special guy who wanted to
raise kids I think it's great because
comedy you know is great success is good
money is good all those things are good
but having a family and like you know
bringing up to one or two children to be
kind of alt-right sympathizing
reactionary podcast Psychopaths like
really I'd raise some of the worst
people I know that have ever existed
like really bad
like really really bad inconsiderate
people because I'd have money so they'd
have money but they'd also be like I
think very bad people which excites me a
little bit it's very fun it feels like
it would be really fun I feel like you
know you're so aware yeah and that's
like it's keeping you from doing it now
but I think we all know that it's in the
cards this is gonna happen I think so
when you're in your 50s and you're like
a low T yes okay because right now
you're you're at your Peak you've got to
get out there and [__] and you've got to
go and you can how you can't be tied
down by like having to like worry about
like a child dying oh no when you can do
other things yeah yeah don't do that
don't do it right now I wouldn't do it
now but then later on it's a good idea
to like you know you have a child yeah
and you by godsend is Chinese which I
love I love because it's something
different yeah engines are so they're so
cute they're not only are cute they are
very competent they're intelligent smart
do you think that's just innate or is it
it's named he's very cold he doesn't
attach to his mother or father they've
commented on this at the school he
doesn't care when he's dropped off he
won't even give them a look because they
are that they are the master race
they're in they're like they are really
[__] hard they really are and they so
are Asian kids are so much better than
our kids no he's just he does his own
thing he doesn't care we even had in my
school uh very small school yeah there's
a couple one of the Asian kids they just
dominate not just had the 4.2 GPA
and was a classical trained pianist but
she also was dominant I think in on the
swim team and you're like this is all
fast this is across the board high
performance yeah it's incredible I want
my kid to be a trans athlete yeah like I
want you know what I mean like if I had
a kid I'd want them to be embroiled in a
massive controversy like something about
like because otherwise why why even have
like Leah Thomas's parents are probably
really proud be like that's my son
daughter [__] everyone up in there
like you know what I mean like I'd want
my daughter son son daughter yeah to be
kind of one of those people is like
breaking boundaries I love by the way I
don't agree with Leah Thomas taking all
these girls titles but there is
something funny about seeing these
exasperated female swimmers or like at
the end of their rope and they're like I
was at the locker room and she had her
[__] out and no one prepared me for it
and it's again that seems kind of unfair
but it's also very funny it's very funny
it's also funny when they're like you
were the number one or two ranked
swimmer yeah and then a person came in
and blew your records away you're like
oh I'll never catch this never like it's
so far and away she's her records she
was like 700 yes yes as a man which is
like an incredible swimmer for sure
right but switched over transitioned and
blew like made World Records I was on a
swim team for many years my mother was a
swim coach really yes and I was a
lifeguard it's hard to believe now
because I've I've left that path yeah
but I was a swimmer I'm still a very
good swimmer and I was on a swim team
and it it makes you gay yeah because
really yes well do you blame swimming
well because you're just in a room with
Cox how lovely the whole time so my my
past the first time I really took in Cox
oh yeah absolutely yes no I saw this guy
William who had a fully adult penis at
the time I didn't and he was the same
age and I was like this is I'm [__]
this guy and I didn't see I hadn't seen
I was on the swim team I was like eight
or nine and you see pubes yeah I hadn't
seen pubes on an eight or nine year old
no no because other older kids
[__] is this right yeah wow so that's so
swimming in general is a very weird
crazy gay sport
I like that it's become the Battleground
because no one cares about it either
nobody no one cares about swimming and
at all swimmers have they're ripped they
have great bodies but no one really
cares occasionally the Olympics you go
oh that's nice but I like that it's
become this you know no one cares right
it's not the thing anyone cares about no
one but what's great is it's this
cultural Battleground where people are
screaming these people we've never heard
from before and never will again sure
are coming out and going I'm a female
swimmer and I deserve respect
outside of this people would have went
just shut the [__] up yeah they would
have said that to us she would have went
I must I I have on third ranked in the
hundred freestyle and they would have
won shut the [__] up you mean nothing
because they don't but now I think it's
funny
I mean I'm probably saying something so
stupid and like base but like shouldn't
you cut your painter off if you're fully
agree and it's more aerodynamic
that's I don't believe some of these are
you going for time or not yeah all that
drag yes are we going for time I think
some people are unsure if they're gonna
stay the other way oh that's interesting
they're hedging their bets when they're
like I'm detransitioning in case I want
to change my mind later yes does this
person take hormones like to this person
I think maybe probably yeah yeah
for sure but she's got the hog does she
have tits yeah she has tits are they
good they're not great are they smoking
like traps like most female swimmers
have the big shoulders
from a butterfly yeah those lats are
wild ones but I love that we're debating
this now as a country like there's going
to be a congressman that comes out soon
and goes hey cut off the hog if you want
to be if you want to be a female swimmer
you've got to cut off your dick yeah you
know I mean I kind of feel like
shouldn't there just be a baseline
Criterion on the women's team yeah like
okay I understand you identified what's
Leah Thomas height and weight can you do
that she's not trying at all to look
like no like no trying she's done less
work on it than anyone I've ever seen
she literally just showed up put a
bathing cap on right and a onesie I'm
like I'm a woman that doesn't seem six
one her weight is not 132. no at least a
Dylan Mulvaney one is trying to be a
woman or they'll be it a psychotic one
person yeah what is the origin so
annoying of this per of Dylan so Dylan
was an effeminate gay man who was I
believe on Broadway or something oh okay
a singer an actor or something like that
and then uh decided to transition and
then did this blog or something where
she was like every day she's like I've
been a girlfriend three days days so it
started during coven but you can see
what real effort looks like here yes she
for sure loves it she loves me I mean
some of these guys she's trying she's
trying some of these guys that
transition especially like in their 50s
and 60s you're like yeah
you got to put it into another gear like
this is not there's something about
sitting down with your kid and going if
you're gonna transition you gotta try
you gotta try like this family will
stand behind you but you gotta try yeah
you gotta get a [__] you gotta get tits
you gotta look good nails done you got a
makeup hair done I would actually say
the you know some people when they're
aging you're like hey you know just age
right with the face but older dudes who
are transitioning I would say start with
the facelift get yourself you have a big
old Basset Hound face you look like a
Droopy Dog that's true like I'm abroad
and you're like yeah it's like a [__]
oil tanker worker it's uh like you gotta
pull this [__] up shave off a lot of
your face Caitlyn Jenner did it she did
it late in life but her work looks
really because she spent the money to at
least like go I'm you know I'm trying to
like Caitlyn had I think the right type
of this is the way to get people to get
on the side of trans people she
transitioned and then immediately said
I'm against gay marriage and I'm voting
for Donald Trump
immediately and that and by the way
that's exactly it yeah like I don't know
why the trans Community hasn't tried
that like just try try to be a little
more conservative like why are they not
trans people being like hey I like
[Laughter]
why aren't trans people being like
actually the cops are of a vital
function in our society yeah yeah and I
like the cops like why aren't they You
Gotta Throw to get full equality you got
to throw some of your own people yes
under under the bus yeah especially when
they've already been long dead yeah so
for me if I wanted to move in like a
nice straight Community like you people
live in sure I would say something like
I'm sure a few of those people at
Stonewall were acting up yeah yeah you
know what I mean a few of them needed to
I get it I get why they have so the
trans people have to like first of all
they merged with the fat people which is
better trans people came out and were
like they were like they're like fat act
and a lot of them are fat yeah they have
to clean it up because if gay men first
look like me they wouldn't have worked
gay men came out looking athletic better
than everyone sharp better and then
everyone eased into it and then they
accepted different types it came in but
like this idea that like people have to
it's like the Sam Smith thing people
like oh people are so transphobic I'm
like you can't be like hey I'm
non-binary and I look like a plumber and
I'm wearing a panties yeah yeah how much
can Americans accept every trans person
should be super hot to begin with to
begin with let's roll out the hot ones
first yes you should you know what we
should all be fooled like you should be
like there's no [__] way right so
really yeah and then be like oh wow get
us on board with that for a while yeah
and then introduce everything well so
yeah so like the swimsuit edition
there's a trans lady on that one yeah
and she kind of works out that blonde
super hot super hot yeah there's a lot
of very hot trans people and we're we're
losing that which is sad and they
shouldn't [__] with Bud Light I think
that was the big mistake yeah it was a
disaster don't do that it was a disaster
she's pretty blondely she's got big tits
no not this not this broad that's a
trans that is I don't know if it is but
the one that I know of that they
recently put her on is a blonde woman
okay big hands I think it's just like my
perspective is like hey when you're when
you're like
I mean convincing no that's Kim Petras
she did the song with Sam Smith yeah I
mean this is the kind that's what I'm
saying I want I like to be to the point
where I go like oh I [__] this chick
and then she pulls her dick out and I go
I guess I still will you know like that
that's exactly right you know that
fooled I want to be completely yeah you
want to be thrown yeah you want to be
thrown and I think that is the way to
get especially like if you're talking
about part of the of the country being
transphobic you gotta [__] right
really fool them you got a 100 because I
think people are afraid of teachers
turning their kids into 300 pound trans
Communists yeah baby you're not worried
about their kids being like hot trans
like if if if if literally you had a
meeting and went they're going trans we
can't stop it but they're gonna be hot I
know they're gonna be hot at least some
of the parents would be like hey yeah I
got a hot trans kid as opposed to like
some fat disgusting trans commune well
same with the non-binaries if the
non-binary community weren't always
obese girls with purple hair yeah
piercings I might be more on board with
them too yes or if those obese girls
with purple hair started coming out and
going we don't need welfare get a
[__] job you lazy piece of [__] then
Republicans would start going uh yeah we
disagree with that they'd start using
the pronouns they'd be like we disagree
with them uh they are making some
interesting points though we do feel a
social safety and it can lull people
into
I love Helix mattresses it gave me some
mattresses I put them in my house
everybody that visits loves them I'm
telling you right now
I I was skeptical
of the Helix mattress I didn't believe
in it and then they sent me one and I
was sleeping on it I'm like this is one
of the most comfortable things I've ever
been on literally and all my friends
that visit my home
are all like dude what are those beds
and I'm like they're helix and like my
friends are so happy which is rare
because they're usually miserable bitter
people that have a lot of problems and
the resentments that have built up over
years of kind of being near do Wells and
you know failing and having near success
but I have a lot of very vicious and
angry human beings I'm near but the
sleep they have so much sleep and um
there's no better way to test out a new
mattress and by sleeping on it in your
own home they offer a hundred night
trial 10 to 15 year warranty to try out
your new Helix mattress everyone's
unique everyone sleeps differently
that's why Helix has several mattress
models to choose from each design for a
specific sleep positions and feel
preferences I'm telling you
I love Helix it's like so amazing that I
get to even offer you this deal
they're offering 20 off all mattresses
and two free pillows for our listeners
go to Helix sleep.com timd that's Helix
sleep.com slash Tim D this is their best
offer yet and it won't last long with
Helix better sleep starts now I mean so
true you guys have kids you have to
believe you have to have some hope for
the country right that's like something
that you guys have to have with kids
because you have to have a lot of my
friends go Tim your podcast is funny but
it's so dark sometimes that like you
know I have kids and I want to just
think of good thoughts and you know you
get lost in the hub because kids that's
all kids are they give you hope kids are
all are nothing but hope yeah because
you just see you see them from being
this helpless thing right a blob that
can't do anything and then this progress
that happens and you see them their
personality shape and yeah like the
distress they're your distraction
actually from the Hopeless world that
you can also and you go like oh no
there's there's hope in this and them
but yeah I mean I wonder if my parents
ever saw me as hope
it's just such an interesting thing to
think about like if my parents were ever
like well he's gay and uh he's on
cocaine he's stealing money he's getting
fatter and he's enthusiastically
supporting the Iraq War
um but he's our he's our Beacon of Hope
we love him he's hope
you know you know what I I did have this
thought yesterday
um when I was micro dosing on mushrooms
is that our generation the Gen X we're
so proud of how hard we are and how yes
we were bullied and [__] you and you
know [__] this and that and then these
kids are all about acceptance and love
yeah and you're just like well that that
is a change for them it is a change who
knows how that's going to end up in the
real world how these kids are going to
fare creating society and doing things
but I don't know it does feel kind of
hopeful doesn't it it does I think a lot
of the changes that are happening are
positive and uh you know people
obviously being more kind and
considerate of each other is is great
you know
that's not as fun well
the the worry is the concern is on on
you know the
how does that work see
a lot of that seems to be getting what
you want a lot of this culture is about
getting what you want this person called
me the thing I wanted to be called and I
feel this way because this person is
validating me instead of this idea of
like that person should not affect you
100 so I I understand that we're trying
to create a gentler World which is good
but I think
part of what we're doing is we're giving
people the idea that like their self
concept is reliant on other people and
isn't that Just an Illusion ultimately
like yes if even if you buy if you're
like oh everyone finally called me what
I wanted and you're like well you're
never like everyone's never going so
right you got the people that you
interact with to do it so I guess you
just kind of formed your own reality
here yeah isn't it kind of an illusion
that you're gonna
have everyone in because that's not how
the world Works no people are gonna say
what they want to say they're going to
use terms they want to use yeah look
people are going to accept you or not
accept you and not accepting you is
actually kind of reality right it's like
reality it's like saying like I want to
get to the point where everybody likes
my stand-up or my podcast it'll never
happen yeah so like you're just
it feels like a wasted effort in a lot
of way when you see somebody putting so
much energy into
use the right term for me it's exhausted
right it's an exhausting existence that
you have and it's annoying it's just
annoying like if you put it in your
[__] email you know what I mean like
as your signature you're like and by the
way my pronouns are it's like
[__] I don't even know you and
you're gonna start with that [__] like
yeah I don't care and I wasn't
questioning it yeah I wasn't reading
your email like God I wonder what
[__] pronoun it's it's I it's part of
like I think everybody
is very very concerned with how they
appear yeah and I grew up with a lot of
people uh who who didn't care and they
there was a virtue and not caring yeah
they didn't care and I think that's
completely gone 100 so because the
Millennials came in and they were like
we're Strivers we're Achievers we like
ribbons and bows and we like to be told
we're good and here's my college essay
and here's my these are my LSAT scores
my SATs and I'm at the right school with
the right people I have the right
internship it was very checklist type of
you know these striving kind of
insufferable exhausting careerist uh you
know driven kind of empty vessels that
needed to be filled up with approval all
the time all the time and I felt like
that was very exhausting and like that
to me is those are the people right now
who who are kind of manufacturing
culture that's why like there's
everything's a BuzzFeed quiz or uh how
fatphobic you or were you racist to the
man on the train or whatever it is it's
like because people constantly want to
grade themselves and tell everybody how
good they're doing yeah right you know
and it came from that culture of like
wanting to be it's so funny sorry no and
it's also in
put it like okay if you go to a
bookstore here in Austin it'll be like
be inclusive
um or in San Francisco you'll see signs
that are like end racism you're like
dude this sign doesn't need to be in
this city right put that sign in [__]
Mobile Alabama yeah I mean like it's all
an echo chamber of like high-fiving each
other yeah if you put that sign in
Mobile Alabama the guns come out right
yeah because we have yeah but at least
it'll be changing it's also think about
it just think about those two words
could anything
could anything mean less
than end racism
could anything have less of an action
plan than the words end rate like it
would it's so
completely divorced it's designed for
you to go right on and then move on yeah
there's nothing specific plan it's like
when Gary Vanier Chuck goes hustle and
you're like thanks there's nothing about
it it has any real world implication and
racism means nothing it means nothing
stop it okay stop hating and also you
you always you're anyone who's nodding
at that like
they but they they're not racist to
begin with right and somebody who who is
racist is just reads that and goes oh
[__] you I hate right right like these
Muslims it's not even they don't even
internalize that they're racist they're
like they're like they're like well I'm
not racist but I'm like the Koreans are
a problem yeah like it's never like you
know what I mean yes
yeah
um so much garlic food I you know I take
like with with our kids and I know Tom
is always like that's an incorrect
thought Christina that's so [__]
bizarre but I want to raise them more
Gen X than anything like just go out
there and be a tiger dude and my kids
are gonna eat your [__] [__] kids
alive yeah I thought you were gonna say
my kids are going to eat your [__] well
they are I'm right here these boys I'm
showing them to where the clinic that
was wild she's like I'm raising them
tigers and my kids are going to eat your
[__] I'm like this is a very
interesting [__] yeah heterosexual we
know this but yeah like guys we're gonna
know how to munch boxes yeah sure but I
don't I don't know I don't buy into all
this cultural stuff too I don't know
that it's real like you said it feels
very performative though doesn't it it's
all performative and everyone's gonna
kill each other
let me segue because I did write a book
and I want to talk about this on this
episode because I like both of you and
and it's going to get better views than
the other ones
that's why I'm bringing it up now I
wrote a book and we'll Travis will edit
the uh uh the whatever graphic into the
thing and and you have a book yes which
is [__] awesome I do and it just
actually came out in um don't show his
book show his book no no but there it is
there's there's Tim's mine just got
reprinted it just got the paperback
release just came out but this looks
awesome you're you're titled death by
Boomers how the worst generation
destroyed the planet but first a child
this is an amazing title No it's it's
great and what it is is my father is 70
and my mother is God only knows where
she she may not be with us anymore but
what I wanted to do before they died was
just one more disgraceful moment yeah
like a head hung low moment where I
could share all these like horrific
stories uh from growing up with when I
love Boomers boomers are funny it's not
a woe is me book yeah boomers are deep
selfish narcissistic monsters sent to
destroy the Earth they've destroyed
Society
um they are they view their children as
an obstacle and an impediment to their
own success for sure they uh were
jealous of their children they liked
when their children failed they set
their children up in many cases to fail
um they were hateful horrible people uh
they were
um completely divorced from reality they
have Tangled themselves up in conspiracy
theories you could find them on Facebook
right now oh yeah you know it's like
they're as soon as they got technology
they used it to spread hate and Division
and fear
all they believe in is fear-mongering
and and dividing people they because
they believe that's how they benefit
they were the luckiest generation other
than the few of them who died in Vietnam
enough uh we've heard about that the
rest of them had Charmed lives with
great uh peace time and they were given
and inherited this whole country and
destroy it and my my friend I mean my my
father you know when I told him I was
like an alcoholic I was like I was a
drunk and I didn't say I'm an alcoholic
but I said to him like I'm hanging at a
bar every night I'm drinking every night
and instead of saying like you should
get help my father goes son like an old
man bar has played a role in every
Dylan's life wow he goes your uncle
Tommy went to Buckley's I used to go to
a place called The Bitter ant like cool
it was it they're so
like my father I was smoking cigarettes
13 years old smoking cigarettes a front
seat of his car he let me smoke
cigarettes and he goes you know what's
good about you you never smoke him down
to the filter
he goes You Never Smoke him down to the
end he goes That's what's good about you
that's an amazing compliment for my dad
yeah so these are the type of things you
got to internalize like that is what's
good yeah he's like it never spoke and
he goes That's what's good about you and
I threw him out the window and he goes
you know and that's like a picture like
you're like talking about what kids like
with their [__] self-esteem comes
from and then they get to you because
I'm used to I didn't I do that's really
good yeah I never saw him down
well I did what the trans kids do now I
go if you don't let me smoke I'm gonna
kill myself
that's what the trans kids do they go
you give me tits from out of here no I
would go you have to let me smoke so
they were getting divorced and my
father's like well he's just smoking a
pack of dick
it's not a big deal I spoke for years
and I would just smoke my grandmother
let me smoke at her house and my
friend's parents my friend Ryan's my
friend Ryan was dating a stripper he's
my friend is in jail now he was dating a
stripper and he's you know the like
Indiana's Most Wanted she was on
Indiana's Most Wanted so like state
troopers came to the house once my
friend Ryan answered the door and like
they were like uh and they were like
doing identity theft they're doing bad
stuff and the the troopers were like
where is she and he goes I don't know
what you talk about they go listen if
you don't tell us where she is she
you're an accomplice so like again where
is she and he my friend just was there
like two seconds and then just looked at
the cops and went she's in the kitchen
and they come and they take this woman
out in cuffs and the Boomer parents are
kind of unfazed yeah and literally that
night for dinner we're all sitting there
and his mother's like you know what I
want to do what about a condo in Naples
how about Naples Florida I mean it's
gorgeous the restaurants are great this
is after a woman had been taken out of
the house in handcuffs they were so
crazy so the book is just a collection
of like these stories of these crazy
people that boomer generation is about
like looking at a problem and be like
can we get out of this right now and
then just change topic yeah it was never
about like I feel like that's because
they were raised Yeah by real [__]
neanderthals at least emotionally yeah
you think about it like a boomer is
raised by someone born in like 1910 or
right right they had no skill set yeah
nothing given to them so no emotional
life no they're like dogs well Boomers
also have this very interesting
victimhood complex like they're always
aggrieved they're aggrieved like every
time you're on the phone with one of
them like you know like my aunt for
example during covet she goes I hope
everyone gets this vaccine because I'd
like to do some trash traveling and I've
worked my whole life I'm like everyone's
worked their whole life yeah yeah
everyone's work they're home who hasn't
worked they're a whole lot like she does
I've worked my whole life like I'm like
everyone's worked their whole life you
crazy [__] like of course they're
[__] but again it was all about her
she's like I'd like to travel what about
me what about me oh my God I just
remember what my dad liked about me yeah
because you know what's good about you
yes you're a girl but you don't talk too
much sometimes women that's nice that is
a nice comment see that's nice yeah I
like that on the filters you're not a
chatty broad yeah yeah yeah
my father would say things to me give me
this advice like we'd be in a car he'd
be like son never overestimate your
value and then he'd go he goes what you
do someone else will do too he goes he
goes he would say things like that you
know like he would just have these like
oh there very like you know the thing is
about these these comments too is if you
were to ask your dad or your dad about
saying that they'd be like yeah what's
wrong with that right they're oblivious
to the fact what that means for me my
parents used to introduce the three of
us to people yeah and like I had two
older sister and younger sister and they
would go my older sister's Maria they'd
be like this is Maria she's an a student
she's a great athlete she's creative she
dances she's like just like just full of
life she's this amazing kid and this is
Jane she's our baby she's adorable she's
sweet she's she's just the most the
cutest little sweetest girl and then
they would be like this is Tommy
he's nice
I go is that it like that's the end of
the thing you were a man you had to
stand on your own exactly they were just
like well we we take care of the girls
yeah like you gotta yeah like you're I
was an only child that my mother used to
like call me in and go
she would call me and she said quietly
she goes I always wanted another child
and your father didn't give me another
child and I don't know if this marriage
is going to work out because I always
wanted another child I've just always
wanted more children yeah and he's
denied me that and I want another child
and I would just sit there and go okay
thank you thanks for that I'd go all
right
so I love my mother and I do love my
mother but she was a horrible person but
also a lovely person yeah she was a
great person and the thing is that that
when we talk about our parents and we
criticize yes we criticize them from a
valid place yes but people are not
one-dimensional no so you can be like
like my mom's crazy or horrible all
these things but that doesn't fully
Define her you still have this stuff we
used to swim she like she taught me how
to swim she was a swim coach and I swam
a mile in the bay when I was six and
Jesus Christ yeah she used to get all
the neighborhood kids and we'd all like
swim at like 5 a.m and she would like
train them how to be like good swimmers
and she was really good she was really
good with that she was really good like
an aquatic person yeah and she was like
very much committed to that and then I
was an actor and she was committed to
that from when I was like probably seven
I started acting and I acted till I was
about 12. and she really tried and we
went and I take it I did
um I just never heard that big break
where it was like this changes your life
yeah and me and her went on a tour for
like four months with this touring
musical Annie Get Your Gun
and she and we would be on the tour bus
every night and then we toured with a
whole production and then yeah that they
put me in an amstell light shirt what's
better than that take a look at me and
my dad right there look at his face I
was just I was singing song about
sucking [__] right there
I was singing song about sucking dick
and the [__] comes out of the dick
he was like this is you said this was an
Irish folk song
um the priest has a big guy
so but like you know she was with me for
that yeah and then I started doing drugs
and she went insane so we went our
separate ways but we I still love her
she went a little nutty and I and I just
at 12 years old 13 years old I started
using cocaine and smoking weed and
obviously weed first I'm not nuts yeah
yeah but weed and blow and some Vicodin
and my friend's mother was a hooker and
sold his garage and we loved her she's
in the book we love them all did your
mom do drugs too never she did
over-the-counter drugs she would take
Sudafed I'd she would drink like
prevental cough syrup and tab she loved
tab soda and prevental prevental cough
syrup oh okay and like Sudafed and like
she loves an over-the-counter cocktail
yeah to just keep her going yeah
she loved an over-the-counter time I
missed the acting by the way one of my
favorite things about getting a box of
Awesome from bespoke post every month is
how it sneaks up on you you forget that
it's coming and one day boom on your
front door the best box you'll open all
month filled with carefully chosen gear
from the best small Brands around the
world let's see what I got this month I
got some cool stuff uh in the Box for
the outdoors gardening like a little
shovel and a hoe and I like that because
I like to get in with the flowers and
the plants no matter what you have going
on this spring box of awesome as you
covered from camping gear Essentials
cookout must-haves and drink game
upgrades box of awesome as collections
for every part of your life you want to
get this give it to somebody who's
moving to a new city going away to
college or whatever it's the gift that
literally keeps on giving because they
get it every month to get started take
the quiz at box of awesome.com your
answers will help them pick the right
box of awesome for you they release new
boxes every month across a ton of
different categories each box is valued
at seventy dollars with each box of
awesome you're supporting small
businesses ninety percent of everything
that comes up in your box of hospice
from a small up and coming brand it's
free to sign up you can skip a month or
cancel any time okay 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com uh enter the code Tim Dillon
at checkout that's box of awesome.com
code Tim Dillon for 20 off your first
box box of awesome.com box of
awesome.com code Tim Dillon at checkout
I love lawyers
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy it's more like
using an app than hiring a lawyer I'm
telling you submitting a claim to Morgan
and Morgan is as easy as pretend you
didn't see that 5 PM email from your
boss they're America's largest injury
Law Firm they have 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
from clients Morgan Morgan has a proven
track record of fighting to get you fair
and full compensation I mean I was in
this car accident and I just said forget
it whatever I'll just deal with it
instead of going to Morgan and Morgan if
I had gone to Morgan and Morgan I would
have gotten my money because that's the
right thing to do
that's the reality if you're
I was in an accident and
it was very hard but it was it was
someone else's fault I think I made a
left from the right lane
and almost killed a sec we're gonna
we're buying Vicodin in a parking lot in
uh Freeport New York doesn't matter
bygones but I still could have called
Morgan and Morgan because even though
she was injured she didn't help the
situation either she said make the left
that's kind of actionable go make the
left
um go to Morgan and Morgan 35 of all
fatal accidents occur between 6 p.m and
midnight
see what I mean
people age 25 to 34 have the highest
amount of drivers involved in car
crashes people aged 15 to 24 had the
highest emergency room visit
due to car accidents it's so easy to get
in action I've been in five accidents
I've totaled five cars and I've left the
scene of three of them
but one of them I I was drunk and I
claim to not be
the other one it wasn't total I was able
to drive away this woman started
screaming at me and I drove my car away
from right I rear-ended her she got out
she started screaming and I just drove
around her and I drove really fast if
you're ever injured you could check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win hello
for more information go to
forthepeople.com Tim or dial pound law
pound 529 for the people.com law pound
529 from your cell phone that's f-o-r
the people.com Tim from your cell this
is a paid advertisement I'm being paid
for this
yeah I did more of I did I did two
movies that bit Parts in two films that
are coming out which is awesome that's
great
um one one it was Eli Roth movie called
Thanksgiving which is really cool that's
coming out and then there's another
movie that I'm hoping my scene's in I
imagine it will be I can't say what it
is it's kind of a a big deal movie and
the director yelled at me and said what
are you doing several times right but
then we eventually got to it but that's
the process
no he's like I don't understand what
you're doing he's like what the [__] is
wrong with you oh [__] he's like what
the [__] is wrong with you and literally
next to me was the biggest one of the
biggest stars of our era so wait
whatever without a podcast tough guy
Showbiz well how did you handle that
because it's so stressful so I mean I
don't even know if I can talk about it
let me talk about it a little let's talk
about it and then you guys can edit it
out if you no we're gonna talk about it
okay because it's not a big deal okay
okay I'm in the film
and it's it's
me and this very big director and this
very big
star
before we get to this did you where you
just offered the part did you audition I
audition okay so you auditioned and you
got the part from that I get the part
okay they said it's gonna be like a
funny part okay okay maybe I have one
joke but it's not you know
I get to sat you don't get a script
every day because it's like super Hush
Hush you know so like then like they
come in they give me my lines and
they're like okay and you move the book
you slide the book across the table but
not too far extended side of the shot
put your hand on the book but don't
cover the title you deliver your first
line he's gonna open the door then he's
gonna hang up the phone you look at him
you deliver your second line he
interrupts you then you wait not too
soon not too fast you deliver your third
line so high strength it's so high
strength I'm sitting there's 80 people
it's one of the biggest movies and I'm
sitting there and and a very very big
star who's like brilliant is in this
little room with me and then another
brilliant star is there this is the
first scene I've done in any film okay
the number one
so I'm like okay I'm trying to remember
like the first thing I'm all the things
I'm like the book
[__] Slide the book and [__]
the book and I'm like I slide the book
and like so I kept getting a line wrong
and and the directors like kept telling
me the line he's like this is the line
and then I'm like okay and then he goes
he goes
I'm like all right I was like I was like
I think I said that last time he's like
you've never said it but maybe next time
you'll say it I'm like
but then he was also being rough with a
lot of the other people who are much
better
okay so keeping rough with a lot of
people because that's his style and I
respect that I'm no Millennial I'm like
kick me in the face just make just put
by scene in the film because it did end
up good at the end so and I'm the draw
on this film
I'm the draw a lot of people are gonna
argue that it's the other two
I'll not saying who they are but I'm the
draw so wait at what point does he go
what the [__] are you doing he came up
to me and he goes hey hey what the [__]
are you doing because I don't really
understand what's happening right now
he's like he's like he's like you
realize you have to do this the same
time every way right at the same time
every time this is like a [__] movie
it's like I I don't get it he's like
he's like what is happening right now
and I'm like I'm really apologizing I'm
sorry I'm trying to do all the things
and whatever and and you know she was
very listen it was stressful but I I
like the pressure yeah it was really
good I I and he's a great director he's
made some of the greatest films ever I
don't mind being
I don't think they'll do anything to me
here's I'll I'll tell you okay okay
the the movie
it's the Oprah Winfrey story
oh my God I believed you I was like not
uh dude I play Stedman no
um
um it's it's a very famous
group of people come on get jealous
that's what I'm saying cut it yeah but I
don't want to cut if I say it I don't
want to cut it
all right all right all right all right
I'm gonna say and then probably not cut
it okay
oh my
God big that's big it's big
we're gonna cut it we'll cut it out and
he was rough with other people he was
rough with everybody that deserved it I
deserve it and I will take it again
you can hit me
and but but it was very stressful it's
so stressful and Ruff with the big
Talent too oh yeah really because it is
what it is I mean I don't I don't mean
rough I don't want to say rough like
passionate everybody's passionate not no
one's saying anything wrong here
everyone's passionate and it's a
beautiful process well that's true
because there are people that are
process is beautiful in comedy that will
say crazy [__] to you but you know them
so well that you're like oh that doesn't
even face it was wild because you know
what
I I got it by the end to a good place
and that's what a good director should
do is to like make you better yeah and
that's right and I miss the acting and
I'm gonna do more acting and I liked it
and I and I'm you know I'm really
excited about it good and uh you know
I think I think I did a great job and I
think at the end
in the beginning
was hard yeah but at the end I think it
all came together and that's what counts
have you been fired in Show Business
I've never been fired per se
from a gig I don't think
um like stand up yeah I don't think I've
been fired
I mean I was fired as a writer from
Chelsea Lately That was pretty horrible
yeah I mean that must be yeah but that
was it and especially because I didn't
see it coming yeah it was one of those
where I never had a job that's why oh
really I never had a gig in comp like I
never had a job like I had stand up I
had the podcast uh I never had a writing
job I never had any of that well you're
the younger Jen yeah that stuff was kind
of out of style no like by the time you
were people were doing it I didn't want
to I didn't want to do it
um I never wanted to be realized I never
wanted to do it I did a few Pilots you
know I rode on a couple of Pilots yeah
Central but I never once I got a taste
of it I was like I don't want and the
thing is the other writers they try to
sell you on it
so they're like yeah you should try to
do this and I was like know why there's
some semblance of security it's like I
can be a comic and be safe so they're
like indoor cats right like that's
that's why they're not truly funny
because they're not stand-ups well some
of them are really fun some of them but
they're not not they're not they're not
you're talking about on stage though
yeah but they're truly funny on paper no
I I disagree I mean yes there are people
that are funny writers joke writers
obviously but like I don't know I don't
LOL a lot at like late night well yeah
but that's that's that gig I'm saying
there's hilarious writer comedy writers
that yes that do of course that write
amazing yeah comedy which but you're
talking about for the specific show yeah
yeah you know what I'm saying is that
like some of those writers they would
also some of them always had like a
little bit of stand up in there and
they're like what do you do and you go I
do stand up and they're like you really
think it's gonna
well it's so rare I think you know when
you see all the people that are in the
business a lot of them become writers
yeah I just felt if I found it kind of
boring
and I thought stand up was more exciting
in the room it was more exciting yeah so
much better
Freedom you have freedom even when
you're not moving a single ticket it's
like there's something about the live
performance that is like yeah so much it
was just more fun and thrilling and like
it kept you going whereas like writers
you know have these amazing lives
um but I think you're more you know some
of them are it's it's I guess more
exciting than I think or more
exhilarating I just felt like for me I
liked being out there and doing my own
thing yeah and I have to admit my ego
hated it when the joke I wrote would be
said by somebody else on camera right oh
that was mine right I want that joke
well they're striking now
and we're gonna see what's happening I
think it's Gonna Last a minute it's
going to last a long time I am behind
the scenes putting it all trying to help
because I'm very good friends with David
zazlov Ted sarandos all of the streamers
are like my best friend like yeah but I
support the writers but my best friends
are the billionaire streamers so it's
like weird because they're my best
friends
but I see the writer's point but like
I'm like such I'm very close with like
these people that I love like I love
these billionaires like I literally Love
David Zazzle he's like my best friend
and like
so like sometimes it's so weird because
he's like why are you supporting them
and I'm like I'm David like
I don't know like they're hungry and
he's like are they and I'm like I don't
know I'm in such a hard spot you know
what I mean are they I I yeah I'm in a
hard spot because like I see them
picketing yeah and I want it I'm not in
the WTA right
and I want to get out and I want to you
know march with them I want to march
with them yeah but I'm in the car often
with a CEO of a streaming company
going to lunch and we're talking about
how to kill those people yeah we do that
most of our lunches we talk about how to
get rid of them sure
and here's the thing with AI it's like I
think ai's scary but I also like think
it's exciting to like have a robot do
all of that work
and and like have all these people that
are doing it now like maybe die
that to me is like a new that to me is
like a new thing it would be so amazing
if one of these CEOs uh with the car
yeah into one of the picket Lines
by accident by accident it was a total
accident well I think I think what's
gonna have to happen is you're gonna
have to have these we're gonna have to
have a meeting of the minds where
everybody sits down and basically irons
out something that everyone can live
with because
we can't keep going on like this
um no one in America cares about this at
all no no not one human being cares
about this I barely care news barely it
registers yeah
um La doesn't need to take any more hits
it's taking a hit the weather this
winter was not good right the rain rain
hail sleet bad snow
very bad
all of the good Comics have left Los
Angeles most of most of not all of a lot
of yeah okay
um and
really the two Comics left in La it's
like the same guy and the two people
that are fighting for dominance of the
LA comedy scene right now are literally
indistinguishable from each other which
is weird and it's me and Matt Rife
[Laughter]
it's the same guy
and we're we're talking about the same
things and so what it really is is this
fight between these two brothers who are
the same yes to try to
try to reach these people Jesus Christ
is this what Matt looks like yeah that's
what I look like too it's these cameras
you don't have nice cameras that's the
problem is these [__] cameras
Rogan invested all the money in deer
antlers and not the cameras because
without the camera no but we're very
similar we look alike we're the same
type of guy and it's weird it's weird
and it's just both of us in L.A like
fighting for like who's gonna do it
that's the photo oh is that a lion
that's the photo that where it's like so
it's hard to that's what La is right now
it's just me and this guy yeah fighting
for Supremacy yeah
being the same you know what I mean sure
my crowd is all women because they're
brilliant yeah
because they're very smart they're
indicator
the to the takes and I did a show at me
Shane Mullen and Big Jay who's in Arena
all women came out in Hershey
Pennsylvania all women who voted for
Joseph mide that's my audience women who
voted for Joseph Biden how's that
do you uh do you and Matt get along or
is it pretty contentious no it's we we
get along because it's like
but it's contentious because it's always
tough to see your doppelganger
all the time and it's like it's like
it's like no Matt's actually an awesome
dude it's a really sweet guy and he's
funny and awesome but
um and we do look different you do
so that's that's that's good I think
that's good it is so cute he's very he's
very attractive from a from a movie or
is that like a cake but I dated her and
let me tell you something about Kate
Beckett's shell you go to dinner with
her I mean you gotta fill the
conversation
oh
you try to talk to her about the Ukraine
you got another thing coming
she's got nothing
it's a joke we're all kidding oh no oh
my God is this real this is
yeah run this is like there's this
comedy people are now this is truly
[__] reality TV show yeah well it is
listen
are getting laid I think that's cool
it's
it's cool comedy shouldn't get too cool
not too cool not too cool it's not good
no it loses Colin Quinn said it the
comedy gets too cool it always loses for
sure it makes a lot of sense yeah for
sure that's why you gotta like you gotta
kind of lean you know we all want to be
seen a certain way look good and all
this stuff but you got to kind of lean
into your flaws a little bit if you're a
comic well lean into Humanity yeah I
think humanity is important I think
technology is obviously very important
but I also think that like the job of a
comic is to like kind of remember that
human beings exist yeah you know what I
mean yeah isn't that profound yeah
that's really good isn't that profound
that's the type of [__] I say that's the
dumbest [__] but it sounds good like
I'll be like the job of a comedian is to
remember that human beings exist you
know
no but you're right because it's all
it's those little things right like
taking a [__] but we don't get
vaccinating yourself we don't get to be
the coolest that's something no you you
can be kind of cool but you're just kind
of like yeah cool enough like I want to
hang out with that guy he's cool but you
don't get you're not [__] like Rogan
is very cool it's cool but but what I'm
saying is that
Keanu Reeves in like John Wick yeah
that's not a comedian that's that's
that's another that's the coolest like
Anthony Bourdain was pretty cool yeah
but he wasn't a comic right no no no no
I'm just like cool in general like who's
the coolest I gotta be honest with you
and you're probably gonna disagree with
this as a mother I like Casey Anthony
I like her free spirit she's cool I like
that she has a free spirit I like like
look at get her out now let's see what
she looks like like I like I like her
that smile right there in the second one
yeah
and that's in court yeah yeah I like her
I like I think it's I like strength sure
I like female strength 23 photo of her
like do we see I wonder what she looks
like what is that expression I mean
that's like oopsie she's like playing
koi there's less of a smile now yeah
well because she's in this is what she's
well she's right now this in that photo
right there she just remembered she
killed her daughter
that's always a rough moment that right
there where is Casey Anthony that's like
that photo she goes you know oh [__] I
mean when you're a kid and they take
photos in school and they're like
they're like thinking then right now
they're like hey you killed your
daughter and then snap look at that
Disney photo from TMZ look at her she's
at Disney World this is what I think is
so cool about her go go up it's the
middle one on top so she somebody got
her at Disney World she's put on a few
pounds she's looking at kids toys in
Disney World this is what I like about
her she's not letting you shame her
because she's out there going I'm living
my best life she's still a mother going
back to she's still a mother she's still
a mother yeah like to shift kids again
no no but but she likes to consider her
a mother
at heart yeah she's a famous mother can
you imagine going to Disney without the
kids Jesus Christ she's doing it Disney
World I think in case Anthony's defense
is really fun for people of all ages and
I think that's what now I'm against that
I've made fun of it but like I think
she's really getting the most out of it
well people like to get loaded at Disney
world is what I hear there's like five
bars there or something what is it she's
really cool who's that guy
I think that's her father or maybe not
that looks cute I bet she's fun to date
though
here's the thing with her she's just fun
yeah she's a good time anyone who'd do
something like that is also a game for
other [__] you know what I mean oh dude
I mean she'll dine and dash exactly
exactly
yeah exactly hey the waitress hasn't
gotten our check why don't we get out of
here she's like that seems inconsiderate
you're like Casey she's like all right
exactly and there's no like there's no
sexual favor you can ask that she's
gonna be like I'm not that kind of girl
you're like she's not saying no to anal
if she put her daughter in a bag exactly
there's absolutely no way that's
happening exactly and I do appreciate
her I mean there's something about her
and I hope she becomes an actress or
something because I think she's got a
lot to give
I want to thank both of you because you
know you are you're so funny what you've
done here is so crazy impressive with
all of the different podcasts you guys
have thank you it's insanely amazing to
watch you know it's like it's it's
amazing and and it's just amazing and
I'm down here doing Mothership which I
gave Joe Rogan the money to open we
don't have to talk about it we don't
have to talk about he didn't have any
money and he called me and he said do
you have money and I said I have a
little bit and I I wrote him a check to
open that club that was super nice here
yeah it's really nice of me and I don't
bring it up a lot yeah but I bring it up
to humanize him because he did not have
any money he doesn't have any money it's
all fake it's fake buddy so
um uh but no it's it's a it's amazing
like what you guys have done thank you
thanks it's uh it's been fun to watch
you uh you know it was one of the people
who I was like oh man just stay on the
path you know like keep doing what
you're doing there's not like you
already made it so you just have to like
only way you can uh [__] it up is by
like stop doing what you're doing you
know no we're gonna keep doing stuff
we're gonna keep trying to be funny uh
you know we're gonna keep uh doing all
the things that I guess you know people
do until there's a new thing yeah and
then we'll I'll try that we'll all try
that the new thing but you um you were
supposed to be at the the CPAP machine
the new movie
um uh with Bert Kreischer that um yes
and I and I wasn't at it you weren't at
it and it because I'm doing a lot of
work right now with orphans in the
Ukraine oh I didn't know that a lot of
Orphans in the Ukraine are being shipped
to Austin Texas
and I'm I'm making sure that to get
raised in good Christian uh families and
I've been working with a lot of the or
uh orphaned Ukrainian orphan but I I I
love Bert I hope the movie does well I
hope all the movies do well all the
comedy movies me too
um
Sebastian's movie everybody that's
putting movies out it helps all of us it
really does to have
um to have people go out there and see
comedy movies and I also hope that you
spend more time in Austin than L.A come
on man well I spent a lot I mean I spent
well everything's a dump except Palm
Beach and the Hamptons that's the
reality yeah that's just a reality you
go to Palm Beach reality is real money
every now and then real money is east
coast it's Greenwich Connecticut
Manhattan Palm Beach like why do you
think Epstein didn't live in L.A they
never went to LA because Lane Maxwell is
never in La yeah the top human
traffickers consistently choose the East
Coast the top
um and that's a reality but I spent a
lot of time here this is my residence
and I'm here and I love it okay I am
here yeah you are you know I pop in and
pop out and and it is something that I I
I was born here and I was raised here
okay so it's a different experience
I'm a ranch hand and I I believe in the
you know whatever the hell is going on
uh but I like it it's a beautiful place
uh Toms Christina pazinski thank you
your mom's house podcast the two bears
podcast with Tom and also say can I say
this yeah of course uh my new special
Sledgehammer comes out Fourth of July on
Netflix
Sledgehammer 4th of July on Netflix oh
I'm in Toronto and Winnipeg finally
September 6th and 7th come see me there
yeah yeah I'm stoked and where my mom's
at which um have you done that when you
've done that I should do it yeah I
would love to have you and we could talk
schizoom I'm a mother yeah
um the the pre-order the book the code
is going to be in the YouTube
description and a bunch of other places
on my social media probably my Instagram
bio it's going to be a lot of fun I'm
excited for that thank you guys I really
appreciate it thank you so much
I